wir hören immer wieder Berichte von
einem langsamen vorrücken bei Cherson im
Südosten der Ukraine da haben es die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte offenbar
geschafft eine Spezialeinheit auf die
südöstliche Seite des nipro
vorzurücken es gibt auch Berichte von
diesen Streitkräften von diesen
Einheiten die dort von einem Zitat
Himmelfahrtskommando sprechen um was
geht es dort für die Ukraine aktuell an
dieser
Stelle
natürlich waren die ukrainischen Kräfte
in der Lage ein brückenheld Kopf auf der
auf dem linken Ufer des zu schaffen und
die sind da natürlich sehr verwundbar
und die Leute sprechen natürlich von
sehr extremen Dingen denenn das
Himmelfahrtskommando aber der
Generalstab hat natürlich einen Grund
warum man das macht wenn man ein
Brückenkopf auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses hat dann W wenn die Zeit
gekommen ist einfacher sein Brücken zu
bauen und mehr schwere Waffen und
Ausrüstung rüber zubringen die Soldaten
die da jetzt sind die sind natürlich
sehr verwundbar und ich denke der
Generalstab versucht die Soldaten auch
zu schützen aber man muss irgendwann die
Entscheidung treffen wenn man sie nicht
schützen kann wenn es das Risiko nicht
wert ist dann werd man sie zurückziehen
man will natürlich solche so ein Gelände
nicht aufgeben auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses aber hat das wenn wir jetzt noch
mal so zzusagen auf die Wirkung schauen
die davon ausgehen soll wir haben jetzt
über sozusagen das Signal was nach
Russland geseret werden soll durch den
Kampf oder eine mögliche Einnahme der
Stadt afdirfka ist das möglicherweise
vergleichbar aus ukrainischer
Perspektive also geht es auch darum
diesen kleinen Erfolg diese kleinen
Geländegewinne die man da jetzt machen
konnte auch zu halten um der Bevölkerung
auch in dieser aktuellen Situation einen
Erfolg präsentieren zu
können ja vielleicht ist das ein Teil
dessen was die Russen erreichen wollen
bisher haben sie ziemlich wenig
erreicht und nichts erreicht was den
Stopp der ukinischen Gegenoffensive
angeht es sollte ja eine spezielle
Militäroperation sein für den Kremmel
und jetzt z Jahre später haben sie nur
17% der Ukraine mit 315 000 an Verlusten
also es gibt keinen Grund zum Optimismus
auf der russischen Seite außer wenn wir
im im Westen zeigen dass wir den Willen
verlieren die Ukraine zu unterstützen
afdka ist ein Ort wo die Russen bereit
sind tausende für Menschenleben zu
opfern so wie bei bachmut aber wofür es
gibt da wirklich keinen wirklichen Zweck
und die Ukraine scheint da doch ein
bisschen vorsichtiger gewesen zu sein
was den Umgang mit dem Leben ihrer
Soldaten umgeht natürlich haben die
Ukrainer viele Soldaten verloren aber
sie sind sehr vorsichtig wenn es drum
geht was sie mit den Soldaten machen die
auf der anderen Seite des jetzt
sind aliciia ihre Reporterin hat paar
interessante Sachen gesagt die dazu in
Beziehung stehen natürlich ist es so
dass die ukrainischen Truppen erschöpft
sind und ich denke mir dass der
Generalstab in den nächsten Monaten
versuchen wird einige diese Einheiten
zurückzuziehen um damit i sich wieder
erholen können an einerit die vielleicht
schon nonstop mehrere Monate gekämpft
hat die wir dann zurückgezogen um
auszuruhen oder um beschädigte
Ausrüstung zu ersetzen oder Uniformen
auszubessern oder die Verluste
auszugleichen und dann wieder bisschen
Ausbildung zu machen und sich auszuruhen
ich denke wir werden das sehen das
passiert sicherlich nicht auf der
russischen Seite denn denen ist das egal
und ich würde ungern ein russischer
Soldat im Schützengraben sein denn
niemand kümmert um die und die Logistik
der Russen liefert nicht das was die
Leute da brauchen das ist anders als auf
der ukrainischen Seite Herr Hz dann
lassen Sie uns gerne noch einmal auf die
von Ihnen jetzt gerade auch noch mal
angesprochene Unterstützung auch aus den
USA schauen also Joe beiden will der
Ukraine Hilfen im Umfang von 61
Milliarden Dollar zur Verfügung stellen
die Republikaner blockieren das im
November kommenden Jahres sind in den
USA die
Präsidentschaftswahlen die Republikaner
knüpfen ihre Zustimmung an Ukraine
Hilfen zunehmend an Bedingungen dazu
angeschlossen die Frage von Neft Schmidt
die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben wann
kommt endlich Hilfe aus den USA für die
Ukraine das ist eine gute Frage das ist
wirklich peinlich für mich dass unser
Kongress
tatsächlich sich eine politische Debatte
leistet wenn wir die strategisch
nachdenken
müssten wenn es drum geht demokratischen
Länder zu helfen gegen autokratischen
faschistischen Diktaturen zu
kämpfen die Partei Ronald reans die
republikanische Partei stand immer stark
gegen Russland und die
Sowjetunion und die Republikaner im
Kongress sind eigentlich nur ganz wenige
die suchen jetzt politische Vorteile
denn die Einwanderung in die
USA sicherlich das Thema Nummer ein bei
den Präsidentschaftswahlen sein
und weil die wissen dass Präsident
beiden und die Demokraten die Ukraine so
stark unterstützen wollen nutzen Sie
diese Debatte über das hilferpaket als
einen Hebel um von den Demokraten im
Verhandlungsprozess
Zugeständnisse zu gewinnen Veränderungen
in Bezug auf die gegenwärtige
Asylpolitik und diese Dinge sind für
viele Menschen auf der linkinken völlig
unakzeptabel die Republik keer wissen
das aber denen ist die
einwanderungsfrage sehr sehr wichtig als
großes Thema für die Wahlen im November
das ist denn wichtiger als alles andere
und sie sind bereit die Hilfen
zurückzuhalten und das ist natürlich
frischer Sauerstoff für den Kremmel ich
denke irgendwann wird das gelöst werden
im Februar denke ich vielleicht ein
bisschen vorher aber ich schätze es wird
februar werden aber der Schaden wird
dann getan sein da werden
Verwundbarkeiten in unserer Innenpolitik
aufgezeigt die Ironie ist dass die
meisten Amerikaner ja die Ukraine
unterstütz und auch die meisten
Republikaner aber es gibt eine kleine
Gruppe von Rechten Extremisten in der
republikanische Partei alles was denen
wichtig ist ist an die Macht zu kommen
ich würde ihn gerne noch eine Frage
weitergeben die wir von Andreas bekommen
haben und zwar wenn wir jetzt auf die
Präsidentschaftswahl im kommenden Jahr
schauen wie wie würde es weitergehen mit
der militärischen Unterstützung sollte
Trump wieder Präsident
werden wir machen uns wir werden uns
alle dann natürlich ein bisschen mehr
Sorgen wenn Herr Trump wieder gewählt
wird auf der Grundlage seiner Ablehnung
oder seiner Verachtung für die Ukraine
in Vergangenheit und seinem Lob was er
für Präsident Putin und andere
Diktaturen übrig hatte und ehrlich
gesagt er versteht nicht wirklich worum
es hier
geht und meine europäischen Freunde und
Verbündeten müssen sich bereit machen
mehr zu
tun der deutsche Verteidigungsminister
sagte vor kurzem falls die Amerikaner
ihre Pflicht nicht tun
wenn wir unsere Pflicht nicht tun wird
die Bedrohung immer noch da sein Europa
wird bedroht sein und die europäischen
Länder müssen sich darauf vorbereiten
auf diese
Möglichkeit ich würde sagen mit Blick
auf die
Präsidentschaftswahlen es fängt ja im
Januar an mit den Primaries mit den
Vorwahlen in Iowa New Hampshire South
Carolina und wir werden da mehr
herausfinden und ich denke wir werden
feststellen dass die Trump Kampagne
einiges an Dynamik verlieren wird ich
würde nicht sagen dass die Wahlen schon
gelaufen sind was seine Nominierung
angeht oder dass er auch nur die oder
dass er die Wahl gewinnt ja die
Ergebnisse die Umfragen zeigen dass
Trump in einer starken Position ist aber
Umfragen sind Indikatoren keine
Voraussagen so denken die Leute jetzt
und die meisten Amerikaner die machen
sich erst ernsthafte Gedanken um die
Wahlen wenn die Wahlen nur noch ein paar
Wochen entfernt ist sind Außenpolitik
internationale Fragen die spielen selten
eine große Rolle in der amerikanischen
Politik der gegenwärtige Präsident muss
jetzt seine Hausaufgaben machen er muss
ehrlich gesagt besser daran arbeiten zu
erklären was in den USA wirtschaftlich
passiert die wirtschaftliche Lage ist
gut wegen seiner Politik und du muss
auch erklären warum die Hilfe für die
Ukraine gut ist für die amerikanische
Sicherheit er muss das
tun es geht nicht nur um Gouverneur des
Santes oder früheren früher Gouverneurin
hay das sind auf der
republikanischen Seite zusätzlich dazu
hat Trump rechtliche Probleme einige
werden noch dauern bis nach den
Wahlen er kann aber nicht alles
erledigen ich denke diese Dinge werden
immer weiter in der forang kommen das
ist eine Art schneebal Effekt und die
Leute werden anfangen nachzudenken der
ist glaube ich nicht wählbar warum
sollte ich meine Stimme und mein Geld
verschwenden auf jemanden der vielleicht
als Verbrecher verurteilt wird also ich
bin Dad durch aus optimistisch dass
Trump nicht wiedergewählt wird als
Präsident okay Herr hes dann lassen Sie
uns gerne noch mal auf die tatsächlich
auf die Unterstützung der Ukraine
schauen wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen
dass die militärische Unterstützung
seitens der USA nachlässt welche Rolle
kommt dann sie haben gerade schon die
europäischen Partner angesprochen aber
welche Rolle kommt dann ganz konkret
Deutschland
zu
Deutschland ist die führende Nation in
Europa in der Europäischen Union
Deutschland ist ein führendes
natomitglied und der wichtigste
bündespartner der USA als ich in der
Armee war ich bin ja jetzt außerdienst
aber als ich in Armee war haben wir
stark dran gearbeitet die Schäden an der
amerikanschdeutschen Beziehungen
aufzuarbeiten und ich sehe das jetzt die
Deutschen und unsere wichtigsten
bnispartner aber die Vereinten Staaten
haben natürlich auch große Erwartungen
ich würde sagen Deutschland die meisten
Deutschen wissen glaube ich gar nicht
dass Deutschland der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine ist
und da geht z um die Patriot
luverteidigungsystem die von Deutschland
die Ukraine gehen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig
das rettet hunderte von Menschen
leben und über 100 mer das
ist sehr guter deutscher Schützenpanzer
noch mal 100 dieser Schützenpanzer
werden an die Ukraine geliefert also
deutschland leistet sehr viel das eine
was Deutschland noch nicht getan hat und
das würde wirklich einen Unterschied
bereiten das wäre das taurusystem das
ist ein exzellenter marstuhkörper mit
einer Reichweite von 500 km das würde
wirklich eine große Veränderung bringen
als Waffensystem und ich verstehe nicht
warum Deutschland diese Fähigkeit nicht
an die Ukraine liefern will das ist eine
Diskussion die in diesem Jahr sehr
ausgiebig geführt wurde und bisher zu
keinem abschließenden Ergebnis gekommen
ist Herr Hodges dann lassen Sie uns noch
einmal gerne den Blick aufs nächste Jahr
oder auf die nächste Zeit richten wenn
ich sie frage nach was wären drei Dinge
die jetzt passieren müssten oder ein
absehbarer Zeit passieren müssten damit
die Ukraine diesen Krieg für sich
gewinnt Frage zunächst mal Nummer ein
die Vereinigten Staaten Deutschland
andere führende demokratische Nationen
sollten erklären dass es unsere Politik
ist und unser Ziel ist dass die Ukraine
diesen Krieg gewinnt dass sie Russland
zurück führt auf die Grenz von
1991 das wäre ganz wichtig das würde den
Russen sagen dass ihre Hoffnung dass wir
aufgeben falsch
ist und dann würden wir auch keine
Entschuldigungen mehr brauchen um der
Ukraine nicht die Waffen zu geben die
sie braucht um zu gewinnen das zweite
wichtige ist die Lieferung von
weitreichenden Präzisionswaffen mit
denen man russische kommandostäbe und
Artillerie und
Logistik beschießen kann und ausheben
kann und dafür zu sorgen dass die
russische Marine keine Platz im
schwarzen mehr hat und dann die F
se für den
Kampf es gibt noch nicht so viele
ähm pooten die das Flugzeug fliegen
können ist ist eine Sache so ein
Flugzeug zu fliegen etwas anderes damit
zu kämpfen und wenn bis zum Sommer diese
F16 geliefert würden das würde schon
sehr viel bedeuten
Herres wir bekommen weiterhin Fragen ich
würde ihn gerne noch einmal eine stellen
ihre Einschätzung zur möglichen
Verhandlungsbereitschaft von Vladimir
Putin dem russischen Präsident und zwar
fragt uns jemand bei youtube ist Putin
tatsächlich nach wie vor unter keinen
Umständen zu Verhandlungen mit der
Ukraine bereit man müsste wahrscheinlich
auch andersrum Fragen ist die Ukraine
bereit mit dem russischen Präsidenten zu
verhandeln also wie schätzt sie diese
Situation aktuell
ein ich denke dassladimir Putin ziemlich
deutlich gemacht hat in seiner berümten
Pressekonferenz am Ende des Jahres vor
ein paar Tagen dass er kein Interesse an
Verhandlungen hat bis sie nicht ihre
Ziele erreicht haben und er spricht ja
von der Entnazifizierung der Ukraine und
das ist ein andere Art zu sagen bis sie
die Ukraine als stat zerstört haben oder
die Idee der Ukrain Staat er hat kein
Interesse an Verhandlungen ich denke das
verändert sich das wird sich verändern
wenn er sieht dass er die Krim verloren
hat denn das wäre dann sehr schwierig
für ihn zu erklären gegenüber seinen und
unterstütz und ich spreche nicht nur
über die 140 Millionen Russen sondern
auch die 50 oder 100 oligar um ihn herum
die so viel verlieren weil sie Putin
unterstützen und dann wird er ein
Problem bekommen ich denke irgendwann
sobald er
feststellt dass er den Krieg verliert
wenn er sieht dass die Vereinigten
Staaten und Deutschland entschlossen
sind der Ukraine zu helfen zu gewinnen
dann wird er seine Haltung
ändern ich habe keine großen Erwartungen
dass das bald passiert und was die
Ukraine angeht sie wissen dass sie nie
in der Lage sein werden ihre
Volkswirtschaft aufzubauen solange
Russland die Krim besetzt hält die
russischen Truppen und die Marine
Russlands die blockieren die Krim in der
sofchen im sofchen meerr
und sie blockieren Zugang zuur Odessa
Nikolaev und andere Orte andere Häfen
also die Ukraine
kann auför solange Russland die Krim
besetzt
hält wir haben es von meiner Kollegin
Alissa jung aus kierev gerade auch schon
gehört es gibt Berichte von sehr extrem
von extrem erschöpften ukrainischen
Soldaten von Frauen von Familien die
wollen dass ihre Männer nach Hause
kommen sehen Sie die Gefahr dass der
Ukraine perspektivisch Soldaten
fehlen
also ich habe genau zugehört was aliciia
gesagt hat die Ukraine hat eigentlich
kein Problem mit den Soldaten s ein
Problem mit dem System es geht eine
Millionen von ukrainen im reichtigen
Alter die in Streitkräften dienen können
eine Million das reicht dass die Ukraine
erfolgreich sein kann und den Krieg
gewinnen kann aber deren System hat so
viele Probleme ein Teil davon ist
Korruption
ein Teil davon ist eine altertümliche
bürokratische Administration das muss
man einfach
reparieren die müssen es attraktiv
machen für die tausenden von
ukrainischen
Männern die in Deutschland leben und
arbeiten oder in Polen oder in Rumänien
sodass die auch zurückkommen wollen
junge Männer
im militärischen Alter die wollen doch
ihr Land da geht's um stolz auf die
Familie stolz auf ihre Nation die müssen
an ihre Zukunft denken aber Sie müssen
wissen dass wenn Sie zurückkommen dass
sie in ein System kommen das gut
organisiert ist wo sie ausgebildet
werden und wo man sich um ihre Familien
kümmert die Ukraine muss das einfach in
Ordnung bringen das ist ganz wichtig für
die kriegsanstrengung der Ukraine für
uns ist es wichtig den Ukrainern die
richtigen Mittel zu geben aber die haben
ztausende von Menschen im militärischen
Alter die bereit stehen würden ich glaub
das ganze System dort muss einfach
effizienter werden s dass sie
tatsächlich diese vielen potenziellen
Soldaten nutzen können die sie
eigentlich hätten her dann lassen Sie
uns vielleicht abschließen wir haben
jetzt viel darüber gesprochen und ihn
zugehört was passieren müsste im besten
Fall aus ihrer Sicht wenn wir trotzdem
jetzt noch mal den Blick nach vorne
richten wie wird's dieser Krieg ihrer
Einschätzung nach dann tatsächlich in
den kommenden Monaten verlaufen wie wird
es
gehen das letztendliche ergebt es hängt
natürlich von den Vereinigten Staaten
Deutschland und anderen bndespartnern
ab wenn wir nicht das tun was getan
werden muss dann wird das länger dauern
als nötig wir sind am Steuerhebel wir
können das Beschleunigen wenn wir
ernsthaft daran arbeiten das ist der
erste Punkt in den nächsten Monaten was
ich da warte ist dass die ukrainischen
streitkäfte ihre Fähigkeit
verbessern im elektronischen Krieg gegen
Russen zu bestehen auch was die drohen
angeht die Russen sind das schon sehr
gut geworden und die Ukrainer müssen
ihre Fähigkeiten auch verbessern und die
werden hart dran arbeiten
Ihr System der Rekrutierung zu
verbessern und Sie werden über
weitreichende Waffen versuchen die
russische Logistik
auszunehmen auch über auch per Sabotage
und sie werden versuchen Ihre eigene
Verteidigungsindustrie zu verbessern die
Ukraine war ja mal das Herz der
Verteidigungsindustrie der Sowjetunion
die wissen also wie das geht sie müssen
da wieder neu anfangen Firmen wie
revotal und andere reheinmetall und
andere Firmen BME helfen jetzt der
ukrainischen
Verteidigungsindustrie und ich denke da
werden wir noch viel mehr sehen in den
nächsten Monaten sagt Ben Hodges
ehemaliger Oberkommandeur der US
Streitkräfte in Europa vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit heute abend thank you so
much ich danke Ihnen für die Möglichkeit
se zu sprechen und ich wünsche allen
Zuschauern schöne Festtage